Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Árboles desgarbados,
rejas oxidadas,
lápidas en ruinas,
una persona que se lamenta en soledad...
son las típicas imágenes
que evocan los cementerios.
Pero hasta no hace mucho,
los cementerios eran sitios alegres,
con jardines floridos y
gran cantidad de personas
que se paseaban entre las lápidas.
¿Cómo llegaron los cementerios
a ser lo que son hoy?
Algunos existen desde hace siglos,
como el Wadi al-Salam,
el más grande del mundo,
donde están sepultadas más
de cinco millones de personas.
Pero la mayoría de los cementerios
son mucho más recientes.
En realidad, gran parte
de la historia humana
transcurrió sin que los muertos
recibieran sepultura.
Nuestros ancestros disponían
de sus muertos de diversas maneras.
A veces los dejaban en cuevas,
y otras veces en árboles
o en la cima de una montaña.
Incluso eran arrojados a un lago,
abandonados a la deriva,
sometidos a un ritual caníbal
o cremados.
Todas estas prácticas,
por extrañas que parezcan
en la actualidad,
eran formas de venerar a los muertos.
Por otro lado, las primeras sepulturas,
que datan de unos 120 000 años atrás,
eran posiblemente reservadas
para los transgresores,
que quedaban así excluidos de los ritos
habituales para honrar a los muertos.
Pero las primeras sepulturas tenían
ciertas ventajas sobre otras prácticas:
protegían el cadáver de la acción de
los animales carroñeros y los elementos,
y también libraban a los deudos
de ver la descomposición del cuerpo.
Estos beneficios influyeron quizá
para que los pueblos primitivos
decidieran usar tumbas como
modo de honrar a los muertos
y desde entonces comenzaran a sepultarlos.
En algunos casos, estas tumbas contenían
objetos rituales o de uso doméstico,
lo cual sugiere que creían en el más allá,
donde los muertos podrían necesitarlos.
Las fosas comunes
aparecieron por primera vez
en el norte de África y el oeste de Asia
entre 10 000 y 15 000 años atrás,
cuando se produjeron los primeros
asentamientos permanentes en ambas zonas.
Estos sitios mortuorios dieron
origen a sepulturas permanentes
para conmemorar a los muertos.
Los nómadas escitas erigían túmulos
funerarios, o "kurganes", en las estepas.
Los etruscos construyeron
extensas necrópolis
cuyas tumbas se disponían
en sus calles trazadas en cuadrículas.
En Roma, las catacumbas subterráneas
contenían urnas
crematorias y restos intactos.
La palabra "cementerio",
o "cámara de los sueños",
fue usada por primera vez
por los antiguos griegos,
quienes construyeron tumbas y cementerios
en el límite de las ciudades.
En las ciudades medievales de Europa,
las iglesias cristianas cedían espacios
abiertos y muy particulares
para alojar a los muertos,
pero también se establecían allí
mercados, ferias y otros eventos.
Los granjeros llevaban
allí a pastar sus vacas,
pues creían que el pasto de los sepulcros
les haría dar una leche más dulce.
Con la expansión de las ciudades
en la Revolución Industrial,
los grandes cementerios suburbanos
reemplazaron a los cementerios
urbanos y más reducidos de las iglesias.
El de Père-Lachaise en París,
con 45 hectáreas de superficie,
o el de Mount Auburn en Cambridge,
Massachusetts, con 29 km hectáreas,
eran grandes parques
con vistosos jardines,
piedras esculpidas
y tumbas ornamentadas.
Las tumbas individuales, inicialmente
un lujo reservado a ricos y poderosos,
comenzaron a ser asequibles
para las clases medias y trabajadoras.
La gente acudía al cementerio
con ocasión de un funeral,
pero también para celebrar
aniversarios y días festivos,
o simplemente para pasar
la tarde al aire libre.
A fines del siglo XIX,
con la aparición de nuevos parques
públicos y jardines botánicos,
los cementerios empezaron
a perder visitantes.
Actualmente, muchos cementerios
antiguos son lugares solitarios.
Algunos atraen visitantes
mediante recorridos guiados,
conciertos y otros eventos.
Pero, aunque queramos reavivar
estos viejos cementerios,
su futuro se está
poniendo en consideración.
Ciudades como Londres,
Nueva York y Hong Kong
están quedándose sin lugar
para sepultar a los muertos.
Aun en lugares donde
el espacio no es tan escaso,
los cementerios siempre
están ocupando terrenos
que, de lo contrario,
se podrían cultivar o urbanizar.
Los cementerios tradicionales
se construyen con materiales
como el metal, la piedra y el hormigón,
que pueden contaminar
el suelo y las aguas subterráneas
con sustancias químicas tóxicas.
Consciente del costo medioambiental,
la gente busca otras alternativas.
Muchos se deciden por la cremación
y otras costumbres funerarias.
Además de estas prácticas convencionales,
ahora existe la posibilidad
de llevar los restos al espacio,
de usarlos para fertilizar un árbol,
hacer joyas
o fabricar fuegos artificiales,
y hasta para hacer tinta de tatuajes.
En el futuro, estas opciones podrían
reemplazar a los cementerios
de manera definitiva.
Si bien los cementerios son
nuestros monumentos más conocidos
para venerar a los difuntos,
son solo un paso más en nuestro
proceso en constante evolución
de recordar y honrar a los muertos.